♫
♫ ♫
>> Pete: IT’S TIME TO MAKE
ANNUAL PREDICTIONS FOR THE NEW
YEAR.
BEFORE WE DO THAT, LET’S REWIND
AND SEE HOW MY FELLOW FIVERS DID
WITH PREDICTIONS FROM A YEAR
AGO.
WATCH.
>> Juan: I THINK ONE, YOU
KNOW, IT’S TOO MUCH TO ASK FOR
IMPEACHMENT OR INDICTMENT.
>> OH, COME ON.
>> Juan: I THINK THE DEMOCRATS
TAKE BACK THE HOUSE AND MAYBE
THE SENATE.
NUMBER TWO, AND THIS IS FOR MY
LOVELY FRIEND TO MY LEFT,
MR. JESSE WATTERS.
NO WALL, NO WALL, NO WALL.
I BELIEVE THE WASHINGTON
FOOTBALL TEAM WILL WIN A GAME.
>> I THINK THE EAGLES ARE GOING
TO BE IN THE SUPER BOWL AND THEY
ARE PROBABLY BE GOING TO PLAY
KNOWING WHEN.
I THINK THE EAGLES, IT’S GOING
TO BE OUR YEAR.
>> Dana: I THINK THE BITCOIN
BUBBLE WILL BURST AND IT WILL
HAVE FAR WIDER IMPLICATIONS THAN
PEOPLE REALIZE.
I THINK JUSTICE ANTHONY KENNEDY
WILL RETIRE.
AND I THINK MY SISTER ANGIE WILL
GET ANOTHER CAT.
>> Greg: I WILL PROBABLY
BECOME 35% BETTER LOOKING, MAYBE
12% FINAL YEAR AND 6% SMARTER
WITH A PLUS OR MINUS 3%.
I PREDICT THIS YEAR’S OSCARS
WILL BE THE SHORTEST EVER
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE ONLY FOUR
PRESENTERS.
EVERYONE ELSE HAS FLED THE
COUNTRY.
>> Pete: PRETTY GOOD, DANA IS
3 FOR 3.
>> Dana: MY RECORD OVER THE
YEARS, I’M KIND OF GOING ADDED.
THIS YEAR, THE KENNEDY ONE, I
NAILED IT.
I SAID THERE WOULD BE A VACANCY
OF THE YEAR BEFORE AND THERE WAS
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY JUSTICE
SCALIA PASSED AWAY.
AND THEN I SAID HARRY REID
WOULDN’T RUN FOR REELECTION AND
HE DIDN’T.
THIS YEAR, I DON’T FEEL LIKE I
HAVE A GREAT HANDLE ON THINGS.
BUT CAN I DO MIND?
AND GOING TO SAY, AND I BELIEVE
IT TO BE TRUE.
KATE MIDDLETON WILL ANNOUNCE
SHE’S GOING TO HAVE A FOURTH
BABY.
I THINK FREE SOLO IS GOING TO
WIN DOCUMENTARY OF THE YEAR AT
THE OSCARS.
AND I THINK THE RAMS ARE GOING
TO WIN THE SUPER BOWL.
IT DOESN’T FEEL LIKE AN INFORMED
OPINION COMING FOR ME.
I WAS WAIVED OFF OF THIS PRINTER
THINK TOM BRADY IS GOING TO
RETIRE IN 2019.
HE’S GOING TO TRY TO END ON A
HIGH NOTE AND NOT DO THE SLOW
DECLINE.
I AM PREDICTING TOM BRADY
RETIRES.
>> Juan: WHAT IS "FREE SOLO"
ABOUT?
>> Dana: IF YOU PAID ATTENTION
TO MY "ONE MORE THING."
IT’S A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT A
CLIMBER.
>> Pete: JUAN, YOU SAID NO
WALL.
THERE ISN’T ONE.
>> Juan: EVEN A BLIND SQUIRREL
FINDS A NUT EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE.
I THINK DANA IS THE QUEEN OF
PREDICTIONS.
SHE IS A PROFIT IN OUR MIDST.
I WOULD SAY HARRIET TUBMAN IS
GOING TO BE ON THE $20 BILL THIS
COMING YEAR.
HOW ABOUT THE CAR INDUSTRY?
I DON’T GET IT BUT PEOPLE IN
PITTSBURGH TELL ME THEY CAN GET
IN THE CAR LIKE A CAB OR UBER
AND THERE IS NO DRIVER.
IT’S AUTOMATIC.
I THINK IT’S GOING TO SPREAD
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IN THE NEW YORK STATE WANTS TO
LEGALIZE MARIJUANA.
I THINK THERE IS NO STOPPING IT
AT THIS POINT.
IN MY LIFETIME, INCREDIBLE
THINGS HAVE HAPPENED FOR ILLEGAL
GAMBLING EVERYWHERE.
NOW MARIJUANA IS LEGAL
EVERYWHERE.
>> Kennedy: DO YOU WANT TO
BET?
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> Kennedy: YOU SAID GAMBLING.
>> Juan: I THINK "THE FIVE"’S
GOING TO BE EVEN MORE POPULAR IN
2019 THEN IT IS NOW.
WERE GOING TO HAVE SO MUCH
TURMOIL POLITICALLY, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE WATCHING.
>> Pete: KENNEDY.
>> Kennedy: I THINK SHERYL
SANDBERG STEPS DOWN AT FACEBOOK.
I THINK MARK ZUCKERBERG STAYS
BUT IN A DIFFERENT TITLE, LIKE
CHAIRMAN EMERITUS.
I THINK THE TRUMPS WILL STAY
MARRIED BUT I THINK MILANI IS
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
NEW YORK CITY.
I THINK MARIJUANA WILL BE
RESCHEDULED.
I DON’T THINK IT WILL BE
FEDERALLY LEGAL.
I THINK IT WILL BE OFFICIALLY BE
RESCHEDULED SINCE OUR MAJORITY
OF STATES THAT HAVE SOME FORM OF
LEGAL CANNABIS.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT’S RIGHT.
I DON’T KNOW.
TRUMP MIGHT BE THE GUY TO
LEGALIZE MARIJUANA.
>> Pete: YOU CAN’T LIVE
WITHOUT CONFLICT FOR TOO LONG
FROM THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL
FROM THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVE
LEVEL.
>> Kennedy: IT WILL COME TO
SOME SORT OF IMPASSE.
I THINK THE HOUSE IS GOING TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT BUT HE
WILL NOT BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
>> Greg: I’M GOING TO STICK
WITH MY PREDICTION FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH WAS 100% ACCURATE.
I WILL BECOME 35% MORE
ATTRACTIVE OVER THE NEXT YEAR,
14% FUNNIER.
I CAN’T REMEMBER WHAT THE THIRD
-- 14.
I KNOW.
I DON’T WANT TO OVERLOAD PEOPLE
WITH MY WEIGHT.
ANY OTHER PREDICTIONS?
I PREDICT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
WILL BE FORCED TO APOLOGIZE FOR
SOMETHING.
THAT’S THE WAVE OF THE FUTURE.
IT WILL BE APOLOGIES, APOLOGIES
SELL.
THE MEDIA LOVES IT WHEN SOMEBODY
GETS INTO TROUBLE AND THEY LOVE
HOUNDING THEM UNTIL YOU ARE
BEFORE A CAMERA SAYING THAT YOU
ARE SORRY.
>> Kennedy: THE NEXT THING YOU
KNOW, YOU ARE USING A PLAIN MUG.
>> Juan: LET ME SAY SINCE
JESSE’S NOT HERE, I THOUGHT
JESSE WAS ON TARGET.
THE EAGLES VERSUS THE PATRIOTS
AND THE EAGLES WIN THE
SUPER BOWL.
HE COULD HAVE MADE SOME MONEY IN
VEGAS.
>> Greg: HE PROBABLY DID.
>> Dana: HE PROBABLY DID.
>> Pete: ONE OF MY PREDICTIONS
IS SOMEONE AT FOX NEWS, MAYBE
SOMEONE AT THIS TABLE WILL BE
BANNED BY TWITTER OR FACEBOOK.
CENSORSHIP OF CONSERVATIVES IS
HAPPENING AND IT’S ONLY GOING TO
GET WORSE.
I THINK RUSSIA AND UKRAINE.
I DISAGREE -- YOU WERE RIGHT
LAST YEAR ON BITCOIN.
I HOPE I AM RIGHT THAT BITCOIN
IS GOING TO REBOUND.
>> Dana: NOW YOU ARE ON TAPE.
>> Pete: IT’S GOING TO MAKE
16,000.